hey everybody welcome to the podcast the
focus of today's episode
is on the innovation of alternative
proteins how plant-based and cultivated
meat
hold this amazing potential to mitigate
the deleterious environmental impact of
food systems
decrease the risk of zoonotic disease
ameliorate animal suffering and
ultimately
feed more people with fewer resources
my guest for this discussion back for
his third appearance on the podcast
is bruce friedrich bruce is
the founder and president of the good
food institute
an international nonprofit focused on
facilitating
the reimagination of meat production
he's also a ted fellow with two
fantastic
ted talk that you should all check out
he's a y combinator alum
and a popular speaker on food innovation
at places like harvard
yale princeton stanford and mit
he's been profiled in the new york times
and many other prominent outlets
and penned op-eds for the wall street
journal usa today
los angeles times wired and many other
publications
our conversation reviews the latest
developments in both
plant-based and cultured meat how
technological breakthroughs and things
like fermentation
3d printing and fungi or
mycoprotein harvesting are changing the
game
we also discussed the political and
regulatory landscape that frames
the alternative protein landscape and
the policy changes we need to realize
to fuel a better food landscape for all
but mostly this is an optimistic
forecast
of food system innovation how technology
urgency and popular demand are rapidly
converging to create healthy
sustainable and compassionate solutions
to help solve our current food health
and environmental crises bruce is super
smart
this episode is i think our smartest yet
so please take a moment to hit that
subscribe button if you haven't already
and enjoy the conversation
all right bruce good to see you thank
you for coming out this will be our
third
turn on the podcast wheel always good to
see you my friend
i'm delighted to be here rich thank you
so much for having me so you
are on the cover of eating well magazine
this month as one of their food heroes
congrats
thank you very much it's really a nice
honor for
uh gfi and what we're up to uh they
picked ten i'm one of ten
very good and the other nine are uh are
all doing just spectacularly
important work so it's nice to see
plant-based and cultivated meat
honored in that way it's been amazing to
see the growth trajectory of gfi because
i think the first time
that we did the podcast in a cramped
hotel room in new york city
you had just launched it or it was
pretty new at that time i think right
yeah we started uh we started hiring
staff
uh other than the two of us who started
it i guess i started it and then i hired
one staff member uh to launch a
venture capital fund uh and then half of
a dozen
more staff members in june of 2016 so
wow
basically five years ago so i think when
we first met
uh gfi was maybe a dozen team members
and how many people you have now i mean
you've got offices all over the place
yeah yeah we have uh north of 100 uh all
told so
there's uh gfi the united states which
is about
60 65 and then we also have
gfi affiliates in india israel
brazil asia pacific out of singapore
and europe we have offices well in
office in brussels and then we also have
team members in london so
across our international affiliates
about 45 people
uh and then in the u.s about 65. that's
amazing
in about a five-year period yeah yeah
it's been good
well because it's been a minute since
the last time you were on i can't
remember i mean it was at least a couple
years ago i think
yeah it's been a while since you've last
been here and the audience
has grown or you know time has elapsed
so i think it would be
good and instructive if you could just
briefly
um talk a little bit about
the background that led you to gfi and
the mission
of good food institute yeah the mission
of the
good food institute is to figure out how
we feed close to
10 billion people by 2050 without
pouring
gasoline uh onto the planet on fire
ideally pour some cold water on it put
the fire out
is basically the mission and gfi was
based in an observation that
economies that grow eat more meat
essentially and the united nations has
predicted
that we will need to produce twice as
much meat by 2050
globally as we're producing right now
most of that is going to be in
developing economies but even in the
united states
2019 was the highest per capita meat
consumption
in recorded history so we were
looking at ways that we can make the
meat
that people apparently just really want
to consume
and do it from plants so it's not
veggie burgers for vegetarians and
flexitarians it's literally
let's bio mimic the precise meat
experience but let's do it with plants
and instead of the inefficiency of
growing
massive amounts of crops to feed them to
animals so that we can eat animals
let's feed the cells directly let's
cultivate
meat in cultivators uh instead of using
you know modern
industrial farms and slaughterhouses and
in both cases
those processes require a fraction of
the land
cause a fraction of the adverse climate
impact
um and are just far more efficient so
much better way to feed 10 billion
people
and also huge benefits for biodiversity
and climate right a couple thoughts on
that first of all
it's interesting that the united states
just tracked its you know biggest meat
consumption year ever
given the relative explosion
of interest in plant-based diets and and
veganism at large like that movement has
really grown
considerably over the last decade and
yet
here we are is that attributable to
population growth is it attributable to
um uh an escalation in median income
like
how do you track that it's it definitely
tracks with income
uh but it's per capita numbers so it's
not a
population issue uh 2019 was the highest
per capita meat consumption
in recorded history in the united states
and i think it's just um food is systems
one thinking so
the nobel laureate in economics daniel
kahneman
in his book thinking fast and slow he
talks about systems one thinking
and systems two thinking and even though
people want to make decisions that align
with their
environmental interests and concern
about biodiversity and concern about
animals
i mean it's the same reason people just
keep getting
heavier and heavier we know how not to
be
overweight and obese and yet you look at
the maps
with color coding and we need new colors
because people just keep getting more
overweight and obese this is kind of the
same thing
um physiology is low on maslow's
hierarchy
of needs food is physiology
and one thing that education is
phenomenal for is getting
you involved and me involved it's
getting people
to dedicate their lives to this uh uma
valletti
started upside foods formerly memphis
meats
out of concern for this and is
dedicating his vocation to it
but as a way to get lots and lots of
people
to eat less meat which is physiology
it's systems one thinking where vocation
is systems two thinking
um it just doesn't seem to be working in
terms of you know turning the world
vegetarian or vegan and even if we could
do it in the united states
you know the us is the place where
people are best educated
about the environmental harm and the
health harm and the animal harm
of eating meat and yet even the us has
the highest per capita
meat consumption ever but most of the
grow
growth in meat production over the next
35 years
is going to be in developing economies
and one of the great things about making
meat from plants
and cultivating meat directly from cells
is that it scales up
so gfi is not in israel and singapore
because we care what people are eating
in israel and singapore
we're in those countries because they
are extremely technologically inva
advanced and because they're small they
have food security issues
which is motivating their governments to
go all in
on making plants from making meat from
plants
and cultivating meat from cells so those
are places where
the technology there can scale globally
in ways that are various right and you
create this domino effect by focusing on
these smaller countries i had
this guy sergey young here yesterday
who's a russian
venture capitalist focused on anti-aging
technology
and he has a similar approach focusing
on smaller countries
that are more receptive in terms of
you know government regulation to
onboard some of these ideas because once
you
get it up on its feet in a place like
that and the rest of the world can
notice what's happening that sets in
motion a chain of events
but trying to kind of push the the
bureaucracy of the united
states is a much taller task yeah
it is it is uh unfortunately a taller
task and then you know some place like
singapore
um or uh israel or japan or south korea
super technologically advanced
governments that
support technology and support
innovation
um and yeah also uh more hospitable uh
regulatory
regimes in a lot of instances right well
we're gonna talk about singapore
and israel i mean singapore just is now
serving cultivated meat
in a particular restaurant there israel
is doing some amazing stuff with 3d
printed me which is insane but i want to
start with
this arc that you've been on and this
ethos that i think is really powerful
and important and worthy of of spending
a few moments on which is this idea that
it's easier to remake meat than to
remake morality right because you come
from an activist
background and part of what i do here on
the podcast is try to incite
individuals to make personal changes
which is effective to a point but at
some
stage you recognize the limitations of
that and realized that
if you really want to level up
and and create systemic change
across these massive systems you have to
approach it from a different perspective
yeah i mean it's um if food is systems
one thinking
and it doesn't boil down exclusively to
is it delicious and is it affordable but
those are the two big factors
and if we can i mean meat is made up of
lipids
aminos minerals and water that is all
meat is
plants also have all of those
macronutrients
if we can hire meat scientists and
tissue engineers
and plant biologists and we can figure
out how to give consumers
literally the exact same experience from
plants
that they get and love from animal meat
and it's less expensive because it's so
much more efficient
an awful lot of people will switch and
then standard tissue engineering
techniques
takes six seven weeks to grow a chicken
from coming out of the shell to
slaughter weight
if you cultivate the cells in a
cultivator you can get that same growth
in six days far more efficient way to do
it
um and consumers just continue to go
about their lives it analogizes to
renewable energy
the goal of renewable energy is to
simply make this
how we power our lives by making it more
convenient
same thing with plant-based and
cultivated meat let's make products that
taste the same or better
and that costs the same or less and that
science can happen
anywhere just like renewable energy and
it can scale up globally
and in the same way that i don't have my
phone here but my phone doesn't have
a cord and it's still a phone um and
it's also a camera but it doesn't have
analog film
um we can divorce meat from the need for
live animals
if it you know if somebody eats it and
they say this tastes exact
exactly to me uh like a burger or a
nugget or whatever else that came from
a slaughtered animal but it didn't you
know it's still me just like my phone's
still a phone and my camera's still a
camera
yeah sure and it's important to remember
that
uh although these ideas are perhaps new
to a lot of people and there's a period
of time
where we need to kind of wrestle with
the notion of you know eating uh
a piece of animal flesh that was
cultivated from a biopsy essentially
originally and grown in what can be
likened to a brewery
at the same time to extend your iphone
analogy
i mean what was it 20 years ago before
you know when the iphone didn't exist
and we lived our lives
incredibly differently compared to how
we live now and we
really don't think that much about it
yeah no i mean it was uh it was also
also 20 years ago that the camera phone
was invented
and we went from no photos being taken
on your phone to probably 99.9
of photos being taken that way or you
think about something like in in vitro
fertilization
you know that was a huge controversy it
was like a complete storm
uh and now it's just completely
completely normal so i mean i do think
there's something about
meat production now that does
concern pretty much everybody who learns
about it
i think people eat meat despite how it's
produced
not because of how it's produced so if
you can
give people meat that doesn't have the
external costs that doesn't
involve factory farms and
slaughterhouses
i don't think it's going to be that hard
of a cell to get people thinking about
meat
in a whole new ways yeah well to further
extend the camera phone analogy
the camera phone or consumer camcorders
have played a large part
in raising that awareness regarding the
ills of factory farming
despite ag laws and all the measures
that are in place to prevent us from
really understanding what's going on
there is a much larger sense of of
reality with respect to how our food is
made
and i think that is driving some level
of consumer change but
you can't really cross the rubicon with
that until
you make it taste just as good costs the
same or cheaper and all the things that
you mentioned so
maybe we should set the stage a little
bit by
talking about the current state of of
global food and animal agriculture
production what goes into that
and what the kind of deleterious
implications of that are
um yeah i mean gfi so our organizational
battle cry
globally is that governments should be
funding
open access research and development
into plant-based and cultivated meat
and they should be incentivizing private
sector activity both research and
development
as well as infrastructure and
manufacturing build out
so the things that governments care
about is where we tend to focus
so we focus on antibiotic resistance we
focus on pandemic prevention
and we focus on climate and taking those
in reverse order
we're simply not going to meet our paris
climate agreement
goals of keeping climate change below
1.5 degrees
celsius by 2050 relative to
pre-industrial levels it's
literally impossible unless we address
food and
agriculture and this is pretty much the
only solution
that scales globally and then antibiotic
resistance
something like 70 to 80 percent of
antibiotics produced globally
are fed to farm animals the uk
government says
the threat from antibiotic resistance is
greater to the human race
than the threat from climate change um
it's literally the end of
modern medicine if antibiotics stop
working so
the former head of the world health
organization uh she said
we are on a trajectory that eliminates
modern medicine if we stay
on our current path with regard to
antibiotics and this is one where people
will say
especially in europe we're making huge
progress we're going to ban them in
europe
um but look at china look at developing
economies if you ban them in europe
and you don't ban them anywhere else
it's better than not banning them in
europe but it's not a global solution
and then the last one uh the third one
is pandemic prevention
and the un environment program last july
released a report preventing the next
pandemic
is the title of it uh they listed the
seven most likely causes of the next
pandemic
the first one is just meat-eating period
because the more animals that you have
the more likely they are to have a
zoonotic disease that transfers to human
beings boom
we have the next covid and it could be
more transmissible and it could be more
deadly
their second most likely cause of the
next pandemic
is industrial animal agriculture because
the more you are raising those animals
intensively
uh that compromises their immune systems
and makes you know step one even more
likely
um and then uh the way that we are using
land and encroaching
on wild animals i think is number four
um and climate change is number
number seven um so you're literally
looking at the two most likely causes
your the possibility of your food
causing antibiotic resistance or the
next pandemic
goes from significant to zero
if you go with plant-based and
cultivated meat and then finally climate
change it's a fraction of the climate
change you eliminate nitrous oxide
from manure decomposition and you
eliminate
methane from ruminant digestion
and because it's fewer stages of
production you also eliminate a lot of
the co2
nitrous oxide is 300 times as powerful
as a greenhouse gas methane is 20 times
as powerful as carbon dioxide as a
greenhouse gas
and far less land so those are the three
things we talk about the most
um and of course for you know people
like you and me the fact that it
uh eliminates uh the factory farming as
well is also a pretty big advantage sure
i feel like the anti-antibiotic
resistance
conversation needs uh
needs a publicity lift you know what i
mean i i don't feel like we talk about
that enough it is such an existential
threat
um so talk a little bit more about
uh that specific issue i mean what is it
seventy percent
of all antibiotics are fed to livestock
why is that the case
and how does that lead to um the
resistance that that could you know make
antibiotics in
in human use defunct yeah so if you if
you get an infection
and your doctor prescribes a course of
antibiotics
um you'll take those four at the outside
10 days
um farm animals are on antibiotics for
their entire lives um
and that's why 70 of all antibiotics
produced globally
are fed to farm animals not because
they're sick but because they would be
sick given the
you know the intense proximity and the
living conditions
yeah it's a compliment um it does cause
them to grow more quickly
so you need less feed if you're feeding
the animals
antibiotics so it has that sort of
ancillary benefit to the
farmer but yes it also means that
conditions that would otherwise
lead to massive death losses don't lead
to
massive death losses because you're
using antibiotics prophylactically
and i mean if people want to scare
google the end of
working antibiotics if you want an even
bigger scare add the word china
to that there was a piece on the front
page of the new york times magazine
maybe 18 months ago called pig 0
where you which you can quickly and
easily find by googling pig 0.
you're literally talking about 10
million people a year dying
from antibiotic resistance on our
current trajectory
by the year 2050 and the reason for that
is that these antibiotics are dual use
they're also used in human beings
so we treat antibiotic prescriptions
very very seriously um and at the same
time constantly consuming them
uh you know for a lot of people three
times a day
yeah it's less that we're consuming them
it's less that there's antibiotic
resistance in the meat although there is
in some instances antibiotic
antibiotics in the meat um it's more
that the bugs
the antibiotics are designed to kill
become
superbugs when they figure out um how to
beat the antibiotics
and then we get infected with those bugs
and we have no
you cut your leg and they need to
amputate right i mean it's um
antibiotics stop working and that that
that's really uh game over for modern
medicine right
and what is the current state of or
statistical
landscape with respect to the climate
impact of
animal agriculture yeah i mean this is
this is uh there are two ways to talk
about this and we're
working with uh some folks at climate
works foundation and climate advisors
and the thing that they're really
stressing
is missed opportunity in terms of land
use which is also a big biodiversity
issue
so the way we have generally talked
about it is direct emissions which is
huge
in itself the un food and agriculture
organization says that 14.5
of all direct emissions climate change
is attributable
to animal agriculture so that's
significantly more
than all forms of transportation
combined
and the folks at project drawdown their
scientists put out
what are the most effective ways that we
can address climate
and they found that moving away from
farming animals would be six times as
efficient
at keeping climate change under 1.5
degrees celsius
six times as efficient as total
electrification of transport
and eight times as efficient um if your
goal is 2.0
degrees celsius um on a sort of per meal
basis
uh chicken causes chicken is the least
climate change-inducing meat
and it causes 40 times as much climate
change
per calorie of protein uh relative to
legumes like soy
and peas so it's a massive direct
climate impact it's what i said a minute
ago
about methane and nitrous oxide which
are 20 and 300 times
as potent as a climate change gas
and switching away from animal
agriculture it eliminates
ruminant digestion and it eliminates
manure decomposition so
just those gases are gone um but you're
also talking about
massive land opportunity
both to stop burning down the amazon
rainforest
90 of the global soy crop is fed to farm
animals it doesn't go into
tofu or veggie burgers um and if you
don't need all of that land to grow soy
or to graze cattle
you're literally freeing up
three-quarters of the land
that's used for agriculture you go from
needing four billion hectares of land
to needing one billion hectare of land
and that freed up land i mean both a
you're lessening the biodiversity loss
that comes
um and chopping down trees which has
massive adverse carbon impact
but you also free up land to do other
things
so you can free up that land for onshore
wind you can free up that land for
regenerative ranching if that's
something that you're enthusiastic about
you can free up that land to stop
monocropping and start cover cropping so
there's sort of two different ways that
a shift to plant-based and cultivated
meat
is a huge benefit to the climate so that
uh quote doesn't comprehend
the massive inefficiencies in the in the
land being free like if you were to
really take a comprehensive view of this
the impact of making the switch is much
broader
and more massive than simply reducing
that 15 percent down to one percent or
whatever
yeah the opportunities for carbon
sequestration and repurposing
land on behalf of climate are absolutely
colossal right in and of themselves even
if you don't
include the direct adverse climate
impact so i mean this is why gfi's
organizational battle cry
is governments should be funding this
transition um governments put money
you know hundreds of billions of dollars
into global health initiatives
um covid costs the global economy i
don't know but it's in the trillions of
dollars
so governments should be stopping the
next pandemic
they should be keeping antibiotics
working and as a part of their climate
strategy they're already putting tens of
billions of dollars into renewable
energy
as a part of their climate strategy they
should be funding open access
science and they should be incentivizing
this transition
right and it's that battle cry and that
mission
of gfi that prompted ezra klein to write
that op-ed piece right the
the moonshot for meatless meat which
caused quite a kerfuffle
among certain people because i think it
was it was
you know an accurate reflection of what
you just said and i was so
happy that he wrote that piece but
there's another you know there was a
sort of misinterpretation of that
uh a kind of bad faith construal of it
to mean that you know governments are
gonna
comply or they're gonna you know compel
people to
only eat plant-based meat they're going
to take away people's cheeseburgers
and it became this political talking
point that wasn't really rooted in
anything real yeah too i mean ezra was a
little disappointed that the piece came
out right then because it was actually
two different things
the biden is going to take your burger
right um was separate from the ezra
klein
piece which was sort of interesting the
biden is like they came around the same
time they came at almost exactly the
same time but the biden's going to take
your burger
um came from some science
into the climate impact uh i mean it
basically
basically was based in a tabloid in the
uk
called the daily mail claiming biden was
going to take your burger
on the basis of a scientific advisor to
the biden administration
um writing for a peer-reviewed journal
about the adverse impact
of climate change of of meat production
on climate change
at the same time that biden was rolling
out his infrastructure package and it
came
right before the climate leaders summit
on earth day
with john kerry uh but they were they
were
separated um but conflated in some
people's minds
right it became quite an interesting
thing
on twitter when that was exploding yeah
yeah it was very uh
it was it was unfortunate because i mean
one of the things that we do at gfi
is stay very far away from anybody's
going to try to take your burger
um so we see i mean again analogizing to
renewable energy and electrification of
transport
um in both of those cases the idea is
not to convince anybody to put solar
panels up you know the big idea
is not i'm going to convince you to put
solar panels on your car right and it's
not i'm going to convince you to pay
more
for an electric car and you're going to
have to you know it's going to be
inconvenient
if you want to go a long distance the
reason solar
is less than two percent of energy and
the reason electric cars are less than
one percent of cars
is that there is still a green premium
and the real trick
is to make the lithium-ion batteries
more effective and
affordable and the real trick is to make
the solar panels more efficient
and less expensive in the same way gfi
is focused on the supply side of this we
want plant-based meat and cultivated
meat as we've been talking about
to simply be the way meat is produced
so we're not the people going
door-to-door telling people to put solar
panels on
their houses or to drive electric
vehicles where the people behind the
scene
pushing to make sure that the solar
panels and the lithium ion batteries
are more efficient and less expensive
that's what we see as our roll
um so we stay out of the trying to
convince people to eat less
or no meat uh because we are laser
focused on what feels like it's going to
be a lot more politically palatable
especially if we can frame it in terms
of international cooperation and
innovation and farmers and jobs
which is a very easy framing to do
especially the out innovate china
aspect of it yeah um so if we can focus
there we're hoping we can do something
you know bipartisan and focused on
american ingenuity or
chinese ingenuity for that matter um as
sort of the framing
they call it attraction rather than
promotion in
in a a that's a big slogan and that's
exactly what you're talking about i mean
it should be
a bipartisan issue it should be
something that everybody's on board with
and as we
reckon with how to compete with china
and
recognizing that that china you know
basically has
has monopolized the the battery market
and outpaced us in that regard which you
know puts us as a nation
um uh you know in a deficiency we have
an opportunity
with plant-based meat and cultivated me
to lead the charge
and be you know the sort of leader in
this space and that should be something
that
washington should get behind and i think
you know we'd all be well advised to put
together some kind of
manhattan project moonshot type
you know wonky brain trust in washington
which is part of what you're doing
to really pioneer all of this yeah no
that's exactly right and
and um i mean we look at solar panels in
the united states
80 percent of them are made in china or
you look at lithium ion batteries
for electrification of transport and the
chinese have 93
gigafactories for lithium-ion batteries
the us has
four uh in 10 years china's going to
have 140
we're going to have 10. so the american
jobs plan from
joe biden it has three focuses the first
is jobs the second is infrastructure
and the third is out innovate china
which seems like the sort of
one super bipartisan aspect of it
it's not really a trick to say look at
china winning on solar panels let's make
solar panels
and look at china winning on lithium-ion
batteries let's make lithium-ion
batteries
right now we are the global uncontested
leader
on private sector innovation
in plant-based and cultivated meat
but we're not very far into the race yet
it would not take a significant
investment for china
to be way ahead very very quickly
and our hope is that we can learn the
lessons of solar panels and lithium-ion
batteries
because we don't think the decision is
between let's have conventional
agriculture
and let's have plant-based and
cultivated meat uh plant-based and
cultivated meat assuming it
works out and we can in fact make these
products less expensive
and indistinguishable which we're
optimistic about
do we want that stuff made in the united
states or do we want to import it like
we are with
solar panels and lithium-ion batteries
and that argument is
you know should resonate you know in a
bipartisan way and framing in terms of
you know jobs and american ingenuity and
what we're looking for is
is something like the manhattan project
focused on meat
um or a space race a global space race
um focused on shifting in this direction
right and you're contending with
you know a regime in china that when
they set their mind to doing something
they're able to execute on that
pretty efficiently because they it's not
a democratic society so
we have that layered on top of this and
then there's this campaign to win
hearts and minds because you know the
the
the politization of this um
is that it could be perceived as a
threat to the american way we're about
like you know barbecuing in the
backyards and
you know the cheeseburger is what it is
to be american right the t-bone steak
and all of that
and for those whose constituents are
cattle ranchers and the like you know
they they're gonna
get up in front of congress and you know
shout
to the balcony about how you know we
can't be doing this we need to protect
you know this this idea that we have
about what an american farmer is that
actually is detached from the reality of
what it is to be an american farmer
yeah and one of one of our pitches and i
think ezra
and his piece put it really nicely he
said something like
surely if we can incentivize
farming practices that are bad for the
land we can shift to
incentivizing farming practices that are
good for the land
um farmers understand what is good for
the land and what is not
good for the land and if you talk to
farmers they're not excited about
monocropping
even cattle ranchers are not excited
about shipping their cattle
uh to feedlots uh they're not excited
about
shipping those animals to these sort of
massive slaughterhouses
um i think we could um in gfi's vision
move to the sort of less meat better
meat
scenario for people who want
regeneratively
farmed animals or heritage breeds and
for cattle ranchers what it would mean
is they could actually be incentivized
to
do regenerative ranching like the folks
at carbon 180 or advocating or
alan savory or that film kiss the ground
like what they are advocating
that could be the only form of meat
production
and commodity meat which is right now um
basically a hundred percent of pork and
chicken
and turkey um and commodity beef
which is you know sort of if it's grazed
for half if the animals grazed for half
of
their life and then in a fact in a
feedlot for half of their life like how
do you
uh grapple with that exactly right we
could shift away from the feedlots which
are so environmentally damaging
um and if regenerative ranching has
promise and i think done right it
probably does
have promise that could be the exclusive
way
that meat is produced and it ends up
being
really good for farmers right and not
bad for farmers right that's the vision
that we're working you know most farmers
would
would prefer to be able to do it that
way if they can make it economically
viable and i think that goes to the
heart of
a counter argument to you know the gfi
mission which is
why do we have to do all this
plant-based meat and culture meat why
don't we just eat
you know grass-fed beef from these
regenerative farms but the truth is
there's not enough land to feed this
many people doing it that way
and as of right now not only is it more
expensive
to purchase meat that way it only
accounts for something like
one half of one percent of the market so
we have this romantic idea
of of the viability of that but the
truth is
it's not a solution to feeding the
planet yeah and i mean
this works as a pretty nice complement
to that because it requires
so much less land there is less land
stress
so it just it makes regenerative
ranching easier
so the really great thing about
plant-based and cultivated meat from a
global solutions standpoint is that it
doesn't require
a ton of coordination and it doesn't
require that consumers pay more
so regenerative ranching assuming that
it is viable and
based on people i'm talking to i think
it's viable but it does require
oversight
it does require a fair amount of effort
um and
the products are going to cost more some
people will pay more
maybe we go up from where we are now at
one half of one percent to two or three
percent or something like
that um and as we replace all of
the commodity products all of the lowest
common denominator
denominator products and you end up with
the vast majority
of meat is produced from plants or
cultivation
but there's still a market for people
who want to do regenerative
ranching and heritage breeds and
consumers who want to pay more
for those sorts of systems talk a little
bit about
the inefficiencies and the food waste
that's caused by
our current system i mean you alluded to
it in terms of the amount of land
required to
raise animals for for food for human
consumption but when we think about
food waste we think about the food that
we're tossing out in the garbage or the
food that goes down the garbage disposal
or into the compost but
but food waste is actually a much larger
broader issue
yeah this is actually uh what turned me
plant-based 33 years ago um i read diet
for a small planet
by francis moore lepay and she makes an
argument that just like
had not occurred to me somehow growing
up in oklahoma eating basically nothing
but meat
and that is that animals need to eat too
so
according to the world resources
institute the most efficient animal
at turning the crops that you grow into
meat by feeding those crops to the
animal the most efficient animal is the
chicken
and it takes nine calories of soy or
wheat
or oats or whatever you're growing takes
nine calories into a chicken
to get one calorie back out from the
chicken
so that means nine times as much land
nine times as much water
nine times the pesticides and herbicides
and then you're growing all of those
crops and you're shipping them to a feed
mill
and that is pollution spewing and energy
intensive
and you're operating the feed mill and
you're shipping the feed to the
modern industrial farm on gas guzzling
18 wheelers that are pollution spewing
and energy intensive and you're
operating the farm and then you're
shipping the animals to the
slaughterhouse and you're operating the
slaughterhouse
so it's both the rank and efficiency of
nine calories in to get one calorie back
out
as well as all these other stages of
production and with cattle it's 40
calories in
right to get one calorie back out it's
horribly inefficient you have to deal
with all the refuse
that that causes as well yeah it's a
massive amount of amount of water
it's a massive amount of manure the
manure is destroying
aquatic ecosystems it's destroying soil
it's you know rendering
soil barren essentially um and yeah i
mean it's it's basically
cities and cities and cities um of
untreated waste like you know you're
we're in los angeles like
the waste is treated but there's you
know harris ranch just up the road and i
know the waste is not true you can't
drive by that without
knowing what's going on there it's quite
a quite a sight and quite a smell when
you pass it
and you know and also as this accelerant
to climate change i mean it becomes a
social justice issue at the same
time because the communities that are
going to be most heavily impacted by
these seismic shifts in climate are
going to be
you know the sort of uh underprivileged
communities or the the
sort of sea bearing you know cities that
are on
on low-lying lands that are just going
to get devastated by this
yeah i mean at cloven 19 we had 700
million people in
abject poverty globally before covet 19
we have
900 million people uh in abject poverty
now after covet 19. um it's probably
even worse considering what's happening
in in india
and brazil at the moment and we're
probably you know like we're sort of out
of it
in the united states and not paying that
close attention to what's happening
um in places like india or brazil but
they're very much not out of it yet
so when you're talking about climate
change or
antibiotic resistance um or pandemic
prevention
and pandemic adaptation it's absolutely
true that globally
the people who can least adapt are the
people who are going to be
most adversely affected um and they're
also the folks who contributed
the least to the problems so from a sort
of
global social justice perspective um
the planet is on fire in multiple
different ways not just climate change
also pandemic risk also the end of
modern medicine
uh through antibiotic resistance and it
is an absolute moral imperative
that we move in this direction as
quickly as possible
and back to the idea of something like
regenerative agriculture
or unionizing slaughterhouses or getting
rid of agricultural subsidies like those
are all really good things to do
but they take a lot of work they take a
lot of coordination
and we succeed on all three of those in
the united states
and the 95 percent of the globe that is
not the united states
has not changed at all so um something
the the real
sort of wonderful thing about shifting
to plant-based meat and cultivated meat
and the reason that it analogizes to um
electrification of transport and
renewable energy
is that if we can get the numbers right
if we can make
the product that people like at a lower
cost
it simply takes over and becomes how
meat is made with all of these massive
benefits right well speaking of products
that people like let's talk about the
current state
of uh plant-based meat like focusing on
that at this point
i would say the majority of the people
who are watching or listening to this
have probably tried a beyond burger
beyond meat or an impossible burger at
this point
it's quite something the extent to which
this has
become ubiquitous and can be found in
most of the fast food
chains at this point and you know as
some i've started traveling again and
you know there's beyond burgers on the
menu at most
restaurants that serve hamburgers now
it's crazy
so where are we at and what's to come
um yeah it has been extraordinarily
gratifying
to see the success of both the beyond
burger
and the impossible burger and also the
success of those companies so
um i remember when beyond got into tgi
fridays like three or four years ago and
everybody was so excited
uh and like you said you know right
after that white castle uh had the
impossible burger
and then um carl's jr had the beyond
burger and then burger king had the
impossible burger and
um yeah it's really it's really really
great um and there has been
significant displacement even at
higher price points but
you're not going to see massive
displacement you're not going to see
this you're not going to see the
benefits that could come
until we get the price down
the taste identical or better
and all of the products so ethan brown
at beyond
meat in his most recent quarterly call
because now they've
ipo'd so you can get a lot more uh
public information
and he said they expect to reach price
parity with at least one product
by the end of 2024 so
two and a half years from now right now
at grocery you're paying something like
more on menus you're paying like 20 to
30 percent more
um impossible is a little more than
twice the cost yeah it's more expensive
and uh people are still doing it though
it's yeah no it's it's
and that that proves the point i made a
second ago that people
right now eat meat despite how it's
produced
not because of how it's produced and
these are very new products
as well so people are sort of very very
excited about them
their you know margins in terms of sales
are just
skyrocketing we saw um in 2020
uh 45 percent uh more plant-based meat
um consumed in 2020 as opposed to 2019
but they're starting from you know a
pretty low a pretty low place so you can
have that happen in 2020
um even with conventional meat
consumption going up um
a few percentage points uh and it's
still going to be you know more than
than ever before
um and so the solution really is that
i mean this is one of the reasons that
gfi um somewhat controversially
is very excited about jbs
and tyson and cargill and smithfield
and brf those are the five biggest meat
companies in the world
about them going into plant-based meat
both because if they see it as
opportunity
they can mainstream it and then also if
they see it as threat
they will do things to fight against it
and we would love for them to mainstream
it
they also have massive distribution
channels they have massive
capacity to scale up um but the reason
that people like pat brown who runs
impossible
and ethan brown who runs beyond no
relation
the reason they are excited about this
sort of competition
is they are creating a market sector so
right now success for beyond
is success for impossible and vice versa
because it puts
into people's brains the idea that meat
can come from plants
and similarly when actual meat companies
start making meat from plants
it really does help the general public
to understand
this and it socializes it and it moves
it in the right direction yeah that's
amazing i mean first of all
to reach price parity when you're com
when you're competing with
you know a huge amount of subsidies that
are
underwriting uh the cattle industry
that are driving that price point down
and to be able to meet that
nonetheless is an amazing thing secondly
uh yeah you gotta work within the system
if you wanna create systemic change at
the highest level
it's easy and perhaps even lazy
to just point your finger at the bad
guys and
claim that they should go away but
they're not going away so
how do you get them to change you go to
them and you convince them that it is in
their
long-term self-interest and economic
interest to make this pivot i've heard
you say this before like they're not
they're not in the business of of of
necessarily slaughtering animals they're
in the business of providing protein to
humans so if you provide them with
a better way to do that that's cost
effective that people like
where they can make money they will make
that shift yeah no that is exactly right
if they can make more money
making meat from plants and if they can
satisfy their consumer base
cultivating meat from cells um that is
the direction that they will go in and
it has been extremely gratifying to see
all of
the have gone to these companies and sat
at their conference room tables and
talked to these guys like what is that
like
um it's just like sitting and talking uh
with anybody else um
honestly i mean this is this is one of
the things um
that i just absolutely believe to be
true about human beings
um everybody is sort of you know in the
dale carnegie way everybody is the hero
of their own story
uh but folks have families and they want
their families to be proud of them
and everybody wants their life to be
meaningful
and if your current story is my life is
meaningful because i
provide high quality protein to lots and
lots of people
at reasonable prices that's a pretty
good story
there's a little bit of cognitive
dissonance that comes if there are all
these
ancillary harms that you're partly
responsible for and it's not that hard
to sort of say yes this is an ancillary
harm but
life is imperfect and what i'm doing is
a net really really good
but if you can improve on that
you know everybody wants their kids to
be proud of them everybody wants their
spouse
to be proud of them everybody wants to
be proud of themselves so
um having conversations with people um
at these companies and saying
um look your product is not super
sustainable
your product causes animals to suffer
your product has
these you know risks where global health
is concerned
uh and here's a solution and that's why
all five of the biggest
meat companies in the world are are
investing in plant they all have
plant-based products
um two of them have invested in multiple
cultivated
meat companies um one of them has signed
a joint venture
agreement to bring cultivated meat to
brazil um and it makes a ton of sense
but
i mean one thing is the the meat
companies are not and just capitalism in
general doesn't
incentivize uh the sort of forward
thinking
that is required for them to prioritize
these products
um and the degree to which they all have
i see
is just maybe the most surprising
and also the best thing
that i've seen that i would not have
predicted since starting gfi
five years ago so when you look at these
various offerings at burger king and
carl's jr and white castle and now like
yum foods with taco bell and pizza hut
what is um
the success level like our my my sense
is that these things are selling really
well and people are enjoying them is
there are there statistics on like how
often people are opting for the
plant-based burger versus the
regular burger i mean it's pretty
remarkable that the numbers are good
um they're they don't have to share the
numbers and a lot of them they're not
sharing but
uh they're good enough to keep them on
the menus i mean the thing about
fast food menus is it's no longer you
just punch in the price like you need to
sell well enough
to have one of the buttons on the
register um
and uh and they're all so you know the
tjf friday
burger is still there the beyond burger
uh yeah they're all still there and they
seem to be selling
and i go in like i go in and purchase
these things and i'll just ask the
person behind the counter
you know or how's this selling and
inevitably they'll they'll say it's
selling really well
so right i mean there were some sort of
hilarious early false starts
uh my wife is canadian so we're in
canada and a
w uh very you know sort of too much
fanfare
announced that they were going to be um
launching the beyond burger and canadian
a
w and literally all of the people had
beyond
burger aprons and beyond burger hats and
for
most of the promotion there were no
beyond burgers because they sold out so
quickly
but it's nice to see you know beyond us
scaling up and getting
you know better and more secure
distribution impossible has signed with
osi which is mcdonald's global
distributor so they should not have any
any trouble
but mcdonald's is the final like pin to
drop here
in terms of the big players they have
yet to really on board this
but didn't they they struck a deal with
beyond right they did they struck a deal
with beyond it's very
exciting and they've tested it in a few
places and we're hearing uh very good
things about the test marketing so
uh yeah it's exciting perhaps this is an
obvious point but
i think it's important to say
that this product in these fast food
restaurants
is not a reaction to vegan demand
they're not
offering these things because there's so
many vegans who want it
they're creating a viable alternative to
meat
and this is really a vehicle to uh
provide
an alternative to the meat eater right i
mean most of these burgers come with
cheese on them they're not vegan
products and they're not
trying to be vegan products yeah the
default is inevitably not vegan
and uh yeah i mean it's a it's
disheartening for somebody who's you
know been vegan for 33 years to
and they're cooking it on the same grill
as the as the meat you know
that doesn't bother me but so the if
you're the super hardcore
you know this is not for you like that's
not this is not the product this wasn't
designed for you this is designed
to placate not placate that's the wrong
word but to please
the meat eater who's just looking for a
different option and the fact that it's
not only viable but like working and
successful i think bodes well for
the future expansion of these types of
products yeah and the thing i was going
to say is disheartening is just that the
the numbers of vegetarians and vegans
have not changed very much since i went
vegan 33 years we've been doing this for
a long time
bruce um and yeah i mean and what that
means is exactly what you just said
uh mcdonald's and uh burger king and all
the folks who are looking in this
direction
uh they would not do this for
vegetarians and vegans because when the
polls are done
even though saying you are a vegetarian
or a vegan is a little bit more popular
than it's been in past years when they
actually do though which of these
products have you consumed in the last
month
the numbers are are not higher than they
were 10 or 20
years ago or not much higher within the
range of statistical insignificance
and then back to what i said a minute
ago 2019 was the highest per capita
meat consumption uh in recorded history
even in the united states so
um the the companies that are launching
these products
are launching these products for meat
eaters who are looking for something
different
which is which is very heartening right
exciting there's so much
intense science that goes into the
crafting of these products there are all
these crazy engineers and
people who are expert in flavor and all
of this it's like
it's wild to see the brain trust that
comes together to try to craft these
products
yeah i mean it's pretty fascinating to
like tour beyond meat
and they actually have all of these meat
scientists because they're making meat
um so all of these people who you know
they went to texas a
m or they went to georgia tech or they
went wherever and they thought they were
going to be
working in a tyson lab you know doing
something with chicken nuggets and now
they're at beyond meat
i'm doing something with plant-based
nuggets which is pretty pretty cool
um but but that underlines the degree to
which
the theory is super simple right it's
super simple to say
let's just grow cells and then market
the cells and it's a better way of
producing meat
or it's super simple to say meat is
lipids aminos minerals and water
plants have all of those things let's
just put them together
and they will be a burger it's not that
easy
um you know we've got the impossible
burger and the beyond burger and in
terms of products
that satisfy meat eaters so far that's
it
and they cost a lot more um so we do
need to hire
tissue engineers and meet scientists and
chemical engineers and mechanical
engineers and
we need all of the products like so far
we've got burgers but we need nuggets
and we need fish sticks and those things
are like super cheap
so we are optimistic
with both plant-based and cultivated
meat that especially with economies of
scale
these practices are so much more
efficient
that we should be able to get to taste
the same or better
and cost the same or less all the way up
to
chicken breasts and fish sticks and
fileta fish
and t-bone steaks but it is a moral
imperative that we get there
for all of these products for the
reasons that we've been talking about
so it really does warrant an all hands
on deck
mentality and it really does warrant
governments seeing this
as an imperative within their global
health and their climate mitigation
strategies
setting aside the moral imperative for a
moment to play a little bit of devil's
advocate when you
when you describe what you just
described it's hard for me not to
you know conjure this notion that this
is all crazy franken food and it's very
processed and
what are the long-term implications on
human health by eating these foods that
are made
in a lab versus you know grown at a farm
um i mean on the cultivated side it's
the exact same
product but without any antibiotic
residues without the e coli or
salmonella
we'll get into the cultivated meat part
of it in a minute but just with respect
to the plant-based
you know foods yeah meat and dairy
analogs i mean
look you know google processing and
chicken or processing and pork or
processing and beef there are
all kinds of chemical baths and other
things that go into
meat processing now at the end of the
day
do the macro nutrient analysis and
you're looking at
plant-based meat it has complex
carbohydrates
it has fiber it has no cholesterol it
has
significantly less fat it has the same
or less saturated fat
uh the macronutrient analysis is
significantly better we're all supposed
to eat more fiber
97 of americans are not consuming enough
enough
fiber this helps with that we're all
supposed to eat more complex
carbohydrates we're supposed to eat less
cholesterol we're supposed to eat no
trans fats
um animal meat naturally has trans fats
plant-based meat has
no trans fats and this is why when the
stanford school of medicine
did a study called swap meet
and they took a variety of organic
animal meats
and they compared it to beyond meats
versions of those organic animal meats
and in just
eight weeks people's heart disease
markers got better
um and they lost weight which the
researchers didn't expect
and they published this in the american
journal of clinical nutrition
i mean it's pretty predictable from a
straight
macro nutrient analysis and then for
people who are concerned about people in
developing economies
um actually you know tofu is processed
and
hummus is processed to the processing of
the plant proteins
makes them more bioavailable for
athletes
and more bioavailable much more
importantly and significantly
for people in developing economies the
protein for people who are protein
deficient
is actually a higher quality protein you
know in the us we're not protein
deficient so it probably doesn't matter
that much
but plant-based meat is a sort of
solution globally
it's a more bio-available and
consequently a better protein source
sure beyond beyond and beyond impossible
like these big players that we have
there are
so many startups that are doing
interesting things
and it's been cool to kind of uh
you know pay attention to these new uh
companies that are percolating up and
things that are happening with like
fungi like they're making they're making
plant-based meat
out of mushrooms essentially and they're
making leather out of it
and it's it's really um a product of
like these amazing scientists who are
figuring out how to use these things
that we've always had in our lives
and and discover new purposes for them
that solve these big problems that we
have
yeah gfi had been had been putting
mycoprotein
and whole biomass fermentation into the
plant-based camp
uh just because people get confused when
you start talking about fermented meat
uh but yeah i mean corn has been around
since 1985 right
doing whole biomass fermentation
q-u-o-r-n
right q-u-o-r-n yeah they're the they're
the biggest of the
um alternative meat companies uh in the
world still oh
that i didn't know they were that big
largely european so they're uh they're
omnipresent
uh in europe a little less omnipresent
here but
um yeah they've been doing uh whole
biomass fermentation since 1985.
but there are a small army uh
of whole biomass fermentations coming
along
in just the last couple of years and
it's uh it's pretty exciting and then
there's also precision fermentation
uh which is basically programming a
yeast or a plant to
create the actual animal proteins dairy
proteins or
uh egg proteins or in the case of
impossible foods heme proteins
um so they use precision fermentation to
create the heme
that goes into their burgers but right
yeah just an overwhelming
amount of exciting stuff happening in
the startup world right
what's the angle that our mutual friend
paul shapiro
has taken with his better meat company
that is
very exciting uh what better meat
company
and paul are doing they're actually
they're doing mycoproteins so they're
doing whole biomass fermentation
and they're doing it as ingredients for
actual animal meat
um and for plant-based meat so they are
a business
to business supplier um and purdue
has a i think they call it chicken plus
nuggets that are 50 percent
better meat company and 15 perdue
actual chicken um and they
win in taste tests against the
alternative
um and the thing that is most exciting
to me about better meat company's
production process
is it is already less expensive than
conventional beef
um and especially as a blend
um it can already taste the same or
better
and cost the same or less so this could
be a really great way for both the
plant-based companies as well as
uh the conventional animal-based
companies
uh to get some high-quality protein and
some fiber
lower the cholesterol and trans fat
numbers in their products and
massively increase their sustainability
metrics
explain mycoprotein it's m-y-c-o it's
not micro it's myco
it's micro it just means mushroom so
it's it's a fungal fungal
thing it's a fungal protein just like
corn it's the the same basic thing
um they're calling their uh protein rise
r-h-i-z-e
yeah um is what that is what the protein
is called but it's a microprotein it's a
fungi
and it uses whole biomass fermentation
which is the environmental metrics are
superb
uh the protein digestibility is superb
um and purdue and johnsonville sausage
are already using it and their customers
are loving it
and it's already less expensive than
beef as it scales up he didn't start
this
this i mean this is all really fast two
years ago yeah yeah started it three
years ago they just had they just had
the ribbon cutting
wow very cool the mayor of sacramento
was there
no you were just there right it was yeah
it's wild
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but
i want to snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of
nutrition the thing is most people i
know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables
seeds beans and legumes into their daily
routine
sadly however without the kitchen tools
and support
very few end up sticking with it so
because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because i want everybody to experience
some version of what i've experienced we
decided to tackle and solve
this very common problem the solution
we've devised i'm proud to say
is the plant power meal planner our
affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for
nutrition excellence by providing access
to thousands of highly customizable
super delicious and easy to prepare
plant-based recipes
everything integrates with automatic
grocery delivery and you get access to
our
amazing team of nutrition coaches seven
days a week
and many other features to learn more
and to sign up
visit meals.richrol.com and right now
for a limited time we're offering ten
dollars off an annual membership
when you use the promo code rr health at
checkout this
is life-changing stuff people for just a
dollar seventy a week literally the
price of a cup of coffee
again that's meals.richrol.com promo
code rrhealth
for ten dollars off an annual membership
all right
let's get back to the show
well let's talk about uh cultivated meat
i mean first of all this has gone
through some nomenclature changes it's
was lab-grown meat and cell-based meat
i guess we're calling it cultured meat
now what is it what is the appropriate
vernacular we call it cultivated
cultivation you can
cultivate your cultivated meat in a
cultivator
um so um i think cultivated
will probably become the nomenclature of
choice
um some people are calling it cell based
um because they did differentiation
studies and that's the thing that
consumers
uh most quickly and easily understand
is not industrial animal meat that it's
produced in a different way
cultivated has pretty consistently been
fine for differentiation and one
across the various metrics of would you
consume it so
basically what they do is they show
consumers two packages and one will say
cultivated and the other will say well
yeah cultivated and they've tested it
against cultured and cell-based and
cell-cultured
you add the word sell and people think
science
yeah immediately gets weird and yeah the
metrics go down
um so cultivated you know from a
nomenclature standpoint
um is what we are using more and more
companies are using it and that's what
we're hoping
uh will become the the um will become
the nomenclature
uh culture does almost as well
uh but has some you know petri dish uh
implications and also there is
you know cultured fish generally means
aquaculture um
so we're we're uh going with cultivated
all right and explain
for the people who are brand new to this
idea what exactly this is
yeah and i guess i should just uh tack
on to the end of that
um when consumer surveys are done
even if you call it in vitro meat even
if you call it
lab-grown meat both of which do worse
than cell-based
something like a third of people are
excited to replace their meat
with cultivated meat once it costs less
assuming it tastes the same or better
and costs less like a third are already
excited about that
two-thirds are willing and excited to
try it
and then you ask people why wouldn't you
replace it and they just deny the
premise of the question
so like most people say well i don't
believe it's going to cost less or i
don't believe it's going to taste better
so especially now so early on when
nobody has had the capacity to even try
it
we feel like the consumer acceptance
metrics are
pretty spectacular um even if they're
like the like
worst nomenclature is used well there's
been this long
ramp up because we're all waiting for
this stuff to become
available and you know while we're
sitting here waiting we're getting used
to the idea
yeah and i think once the two products
are on the shelves um
people are like they're just not super
excited about the external costs of meat
production like people do eat meat
despite its production not because of
its production
and when you have two products and one
of them is safer for you
and your family and if you want to go
see what upside food is doing
um you know they'll stream it on the
internet you know get boring like that
the transparency piece is huge exactly
yeah and like you said earlier they're
like they're literally passing laws to
make it illegal
to find out what's happening on modern
farms and in modern slaughterhouses
uh whereas the production process for
plant-based and cultivated meat they
will stream live
here we're live streaming every aspect
of this exactly so essentially
you you the idea here is
you take a cell culture from an animal a
biopsy
and you grow that self cell culture or
you
protect it or you create these these um
these cell banks and you use those to
then
um create these meat products that you
essentially brew in these breweries yeah
you bathe themselves throw on
like a scaffold yeah that's exactly
right so you take a biopsy the size of a
sesame seed
from a live animal or you could do it
from a slaughtered animal either way
you bathe the cells and nutrients you do
that in a cultivator which looks
like a beer uh brewer um you can do it
on scaffolds or if you just need the
cells for
nuggets or burgers or something you
don't have to do it on a scaffold
and then you harvest the meat it's a
it's a super simple process
which was sort of fascinating for gfi
when we started working on gfi five
years ago
we assumed that we know everything we
need to know about plant-based meat
because we've all been eating
veggie burgers for decades and with
cultivated meat there was like
all kinds of stuff we had to figure out
and it turned out the reverse of that
was true um because with cultivated meat
you just take standard tissue
engineering techniques
and scale it way up and use food grade
ingredients
and that's basically what you're doing
and we know how in therapeutics and
medicine medicine
we know how to do that at high price
points
that's why this two sort of fathers of
cultivated meat
um mark post who grew the first
cultivated meat burger with a million
dollars from sergey brin
is a medical doctor he was teaching
medicine at both um harvard medical
school and dartmouth medical school
and then he went to teach tissue
engineering um and medicine in the
netherlands
and then uma valletti from upside foods
um trained at mayo
and was a heart prof um a professor of
uh
cardiology cardiology uh at the
university of minnesota and he started
upside foods formerly
memphis meats they're medical doctors
right and so they know how to do this
and then with plant-based meat
um it's kind of it's not exactly a
different product but it's a
whole different way of thinking about
the endeavor
if you're sort of taking soy waste
products
or wheat waste products fashioning it
into something that looks like
a burger or a nugget or whatever and
charging
higher price points for it so really
figuring out how to take
plant proteins and create the entire
meat experience is a very different way
of thinking about that endeavor
and we've been using trent twin screw
extrusion literally for decades
which is what's made for you know pet
food and
snack food and that sort of thing it's
almost certainly not the best way
to produce plant-based meat so it really
has been sort of an
interesting and interesting shift
because cultivated meat very very simple
plant-based meat like a gazillion
different ways of thinking about it in a
gazillion different
ways of thinking about the inputs right
and there's this this battle about
which one is the more viable path to
take right
yeah where should we be placing our bets
i mean gfi is placing its bets on both
but what's your sense of
how this will play out over the next
decade
um one thing that we have been surprised
by
is the number of plant-based companies
that are coming along and they're sort
of thinking about the endeavor
in the older way so one of the things
that we challenge especially the
plant-based companies to do
is to remember that beyond meat was
started on the back
of university research from the
university of missouri
they started working on it in 2012. i'm
sorry in 2009
they didn't have a product for three
years
um impossible foods um pat
started working on that in 2011 he's one
of the foremost chemical engineers
in the world accomplished scientists and
it took him five years
to have the first product the impossible
burger
so if you're starting a plant-based
company and you say i'm the next
impossible foods or i'm the next beyond
meat
and you also say for 10 million dollars
i can have a product on the market
in eight or ten months like those things
don't compute
for plant-based meat we really need to
challenge the plant-based
meat companies to forget go
the short-term competition with one
another
on behalf of the longer-term competition
with the entire meat industry
yeah and with cultivated meat that's in
stark relief like everybody knows if you
are a cultivated meat company
um it is going to take you you know
three to ten years
and when you come out of the gate you
better have it super dialed
or you're gonna be dead in the water i
mean i know ethan didn't he
pull the first iteration of beyond off
the shelves he's like it's not good
enough
like it has to be just as good or better
when we introduce it to the public or
it's not going to work
yeah and the thing about plant-based
meat though is that
you can have a successful plant-based
company
that just sells to flexitarians
and vegetarians and competes with the
rest of the plant-based companies
and that is alluring for investors you
can have a successful company that makes
a fair amount of money
um and delaying gratification
to really hire all of the scientists
that are going to be required
to have a plant-based meat company that
competes with conventional animal meat
on taste and price metrics is harder
so they're further out of the gate with
impossible and beyond there
and now we think the conventional meat
companies
are thinking in this way as well um but
it's it's tough it's kind of anybody's
guess
yeah and then there's also the i mean
they're we are the more our scientists
dive into this and we have
um 20 something scientists all over the
world looking at this and the more they
dive into it and we have
networks of scientists at all of the
companies like benson hill biosystems
and merck and all of these other
companies
the more we dive into this the more
enthusiastic we get
about its prospects on both the
plant-based and the cultivated meat side
but nobody's done it yet nobody has
produced a plant-based or a cultivated
meat product
that tastes the same or better and that
costs the same or less
and that's where we need to get to so we
don't know with absolute certainty
that it's possible we do know with
plant-based and cultivated that it's
going to take a while
especially for like chicken nuggets and
fish sticks
um and so which one wins is probably
going to be to some degree
a product of resources um and then
there's also the sort of uh billionaire
that wants to change the world factor
like
if jeff bezos or elon musk said okay
i've got mars
and i've got you know amazon or i've got
mars and i've got tesla like if they
were to say
gosh the way that we're producing meat
right now is incredibly antiquated
and i am going to relegate these this
harmful way of producing meat to the
destiny of history
and put the resources that are necessary
into you know then they can pick
plant-based or cultivated
and suddenly that you know that becomes
the one that will be the accelerant yeah
but i feel like either way it's
it's an inevitability like we're headed
in that direction it's going to happen
cultivated meets going to take longer um
it is interesting
that um i'm sure you know this like pat
brown is
is less sanguine about uh cultivated
meat like he told me like he's i mean
he's all in on
plant-based meat not so certain about
where we're headed with cultivated meat
yeah i mean i i think um i don't think
pat has looked at the science in a while
on cultivated me which is perfectly
understandable he's running a
multi-billion dollar plant-based meat
company
i will say so gfi hired our first
scientists
in june of 2016. and when i
first started working on it at the end
of 2015 i assumed that cultivated meat
was going to be the the province of
university researchers for quite a while
and uma valletti convinced me that it
was ready for
commercialization but not completely so
the first thing i said to our scientists
when we hired them in june of 2016 was
figure out
whether cultivated meat can work because
gfi is agnostic we can
go all in on plant-based meat if we
don't think cultivated meat will work
and the more we have dived in the more
optimistic we have become
and we produced the first ever life
cycle analysis
and more to our point technoeconomic
analysis that included
nda information from companies we had 15
companies and
the government of singapore their agency
for science technology and research
all participated with a company called
ce delft so we didn't get any of the
proprietary information ce delta got
proprietary information
from 15 companies and worked with a star
the government science agency of
singapore to map
the path forward and the more people
dive in
the more enthusiastic they get about the
possibility of cultivated meat
and it's going to require some some
government support just like
electrification of transport and solar
have required government support i mean
it might be inevitable over sort of the
longest time frame
um if we you know relegate it
exclusively to startup companies
um but with government support um our
scientists become more and more
convinced
that it's doable um and if that changed
you know we'd stop doing it
right so right now josh tetrix company
just is serving
cultivated meat in this fancy restaurant
in singapore interestingly
just which was hampton creek began as a
plant-based egg company
yeah and then pivoted to the cultured
meat like that
they do both now they're just both yeah
they just raised 200 million dollars
they didn't
start in the cultivated space though
right they started as a plant-based egg
yeah yeah um and that's kind of
proof of concept um you know slowly
these things are going to get onboarded
and will reach up uh you know
a pivot moment in terms of scale well
when
it will all become affordable that yeah
i think that's i think that's right i
mean
our techno economic analysis um names
sort of
three things three areas um
of significant requisite
scientific inquiry on the cultivated
side
as well as some areas where governments
need to provide support similar to what
they did with tesla
in 2009 in terms of super low interest
loans for factories as one example
some of the ingredients especially uh
albumin in the media
either getting a synthetic version or a
much lower cost version
um those sorts of things but um yeah i
think it's uh i think it is eminently
eminently doable
um i also think there's an absolute
moral imperative to do it
so this is why at gfi
our global battle cry is convincing all
of the governments where we operate
that this needs to be a part of their
theory of change and programs
around both global health uh and climate
change meeting their obligations
under the paris agreement and then also
just getting the the global
ngo community so um break their energy
bill gates he launched his ngo in
february it was a spin-off of
breakthrough energy ventures
we worked with them on their policy plan
around
this issue and they are saying and more
and more environmental groups but we
need all of them
i mean most environmental groups have
been somewhat
awol on ag and land
solutions sure because they couldn't
come up with something that analogized
to renewable energy
and electrification of transport all of
the solutions either required
individuals to change
which just hasn't been working for 50
years as like a grand plan
or it required massive amounts of
collaboration and cooperation
across governments which is also super
hard
renewable energy electrification of
transport you use markets you use
technology
that is clear so now the organizations
that see those as a solution
uh to fossil fuels uh and
to fossil fuels need to see this as the
ag
and land solution so that's really what
we're feeling yeah that's interesting i
hadn't really thought about that you
can't just say stop doing that
you have to provide an alternative where
you can direct funding
and and and interest yeah and now this
is that thing
yeah and i do just want to underline
like you know pat brown and ethan brown
and
uma valetti and you and me and lots and
lots of people like we are
here dedicating our lives to this on the
basis of education
and gfi doesn't do direct cons to
consumer we do
outreach to governments and outreach to
ngos and other policy makers
and corporate executives and
entrepreneurs and scientists
and we are focused on educating people
uh the people to
change their lives in this direction but
education is a way to get lots and lots
of people to change their diets
uh just it hasn't worked yet even in the
united states where we're
sort of most advanced in education the
idea that it will work in
rural china it just seems not likely um
so
this is the solution from a sort of
grand
vision way of thinking about the
problems uh both both browns pat and
ethan
and um uh
you know they can't they come into this
not as
entrepreneurs or i have this great idea
and i'm going to make a bunch of money
or i'm
or i'm in the world of food they were
looking at it from a perspective
of this is a big problem and i perhaps
might have a solution to this
yeah and i'm option oriented yeah no
that's that's absolutely why right
i will take this opportunity to say like
the foundation of gfi
um was looking at people like pat and
ethan
and uma and josh patrick yeah um and
saying
all of these guys have the solution and
then they have a company and all of
their science is protected by ip
law uh which is great um for them you
have to do that
but you want to open source this stuff
yeah so our first of our first six hires
two of them were scientists and nobody
before gfi
had said what is the technological
readiness
of these technologies what are the
critical technology
elements um what do we know what do we
not know
where the areas of exploration where we
don't even know what we don't know
um and let's start filling those gaps so
the first thing we did in science and
technology was produced
the technological readiness assessments
and we are methodically publishing
peer-review research as well as
partnering with food technology which is
the
institute of food technologists member
organization we've published
three papers about plant-based
cultivated meat and fermentation in
their journal which is the largest
journal for food technologists in the
world
we have 16 university programs we call
it the
alt protein project so anybody who has
the relevant experience to transform the
world
using food science across the full scope
and pretty much everything in stem
is applicable here we want to make sure
all of these people
everyone knows that they can save
antibiotics that they can lessen
pandemic risk that they can
address climate that they can help
animals
with their expertise by going into this
space
and we are open accessing everything
and we are inviting everybody to the
table so we have
monthly the science of all protein
seminars we have monthly
the business of all protein seminars and
somebody the other day said gfi.org
is the wikipedia of all proteins
um and it absolutely is it's hard to
imagine any question
anybody could ask that's not answered on
our website you you recently revamped
the website
which looks great by the way but it's an
incredibly robust resource
for everything you want to know about
this world
yeah that's exactly right and then we uh
and then we have massive amounts
of webinars so um yeah we're getting the
conference back up on its
feet we're not doing it in person this
year so the good food conference
um we're doing a virtual version um and
i can't remember what the
slogan is but um the the slogan that we
scrapped was uh
not your grandmother's all protein
conference and
a whole bunch of people didn't like that
but it's basically i don't think my
grandmother
i don't think there was an alt protein
conference yeah in my grandmother's era
okay so that may have been the fatal
flaw but now
the idea of the conference we did a full
day on fermentation
um and it was super sciencey um
well it wasn't it was it was sort of
fermentation 301
so the science and the entrepreneurship
and the policy
panels and presentations were all like
for people who are
in fermentation and want to take it to
the next level across whole biomass
fermentation and precision fermentation
this conference i was looking at the the
schedule
that uh folks have put together and it's
all like sort of
policy corporate engagement innovation
um and science 301 so it's sort of
next level and for people who really
want to dive in and then we
go out and we you know go to cargill and
adm and nestle
and all of the sort of people who are
working in
fields where their expertise would be
applicable here
but aren't here yet and say hey come
learn about
what it means that you're a fermentation
scientist or a meat scientist or
whatever else and how you can apply
those skills here um and all of the
opportunities
that exist here so our 2018
and 2019 conferences um were phenomenal
for getting people involved and
interested and excited
um this is sort of a step up in terms of
the
the uh intricacy of the panel that's
cool
one of the other things that i didn't
realize
and never had thought about until i
heard you talking about it with
simon hill on his plant proof podcast
is the fact that once you
perfect this or not even perfect but
once you get
cultured meat up on its feet it's not
just about
steaks and chicken breasts like you can
literally do
all these crazy delicacies like foie
gras
or like you know just imagine the
uh aperture opening up to i mean our
choice of animals that we eat is
is driven by the history of
domestication
right but sin then suddenly you could
culture any type of meat
which is freaky and weird um or uh
or like incredibly i guess i mean it's
like i'm you know
look you've been vegan forever and i
have for a long time so it's not my
it's not something that like i find
myself looking forward to but just
thinking about that is super interesting
yeah no it's it's insanely interesting
and i mean this is one
uh where pat brown talks about how um if
you're making beef
i mean all the climate numbers also like
this goes back to like these are the
climate numbers now
when the industry is like teeny tiny as
it scales up the climate numbers get
better
the efficiency numbers get better like
everything gets better and the same
thing
in the same vein if you're like
producing beef
you're pretty limited like you can feed
the cows you know slightly different
things and sort of tweak it
a little bit but you're pretty limited
um to beef and chicken and pork and lamb
and like
as you said the limited number of
species who we have
successfully domesticated uh with
cultivated meat yeah um
you're not limited by you know who is
domesticatable
right um so it's gonna get weird it'll
it'll get nutty
right i don't know if weird and nutty
are exactly i guess well it can be like
imagine any animal like who knows
there's some animal that has a certain
taste to it that consumers might cotton
on to
it's gonna get we never thought of
eating before yeah significantly
different
from what's happening now uh george
church uh the
famed tissue engineer from harvard
medical school
um has talked about uh ancient and
extinct species
um who if we have their you know the
mastodon guy exactly
so we could be uh jurassic park like
getting getting
cells out of the amber and and then
cultivating them and creating meat out
of them for us to eat
yeah one of one of my scientists is
going to email me after this podcast
drops and so
these are the like nine things that you
got just absolutely wrong
uh but i don't know what i'm talking
about so i'm okay
yeah well i can give that disclaimer i'm
a bit yeah i'll make the disclaimer too
no i'm pretty sure i haven't said
anything wrong but
on this one i'm feeling a little out of
my depths but i think so yeah i mean if
you can um
if you can find uh the requisite dna
to bring those species back i assume you
can also find
uh whatever you need as a a starter uh
to cultivate
you know cells from tyranus
tyrannosaurus rex or whatever
i mean it is wild i mean you know it's
also like exciting and awesome and yeah
interesting and
fun and cool a close cousin being
the 3d printing that's going on right
now
with this company in israel right yeah
there yeah israel
redefined meat um is one of them but
yeah there are a bunch of companies uh
looking at 3d printing which you use is
a nice compliment
uh to the idea with both plant-based and
cultivated meat i mean that's
probably how we get uh t-bone steaks and
pork chops is 3d printing so but if you
perfect that
and you create a situation where that's
expedient
and cost effective that also eliminates
a lot of distribution issues and
transportation issues that are
contributing to climate change because
all you would need are
the ingredients and the computer and the
printer
yeah i mean one of one of the climate
battle cries
is electrify everything so that's
across climate activists electrify
everything that's why electrify
transport even in countries where
they're relying on fossil fuels because
you will get to renewable energy and
then you electrify transport
similarly if you concentrate production
um even if it's not you know the
localized that you're talking about but
if you
eliminate multiple stages of production
and you concentrate production in a
factory and then you use
renewable energy to power that factory
this is how we make agriculture net zero
emissions um you start you know taking
advantage of all the freed up land and
using that for
cover cropping and all of the other
things that you can repurpose that land
for or even just stop
chopping down the rainforest because the
land is less
in demand even more positive climate
benefits for sure
um it is a very energy intensive
thing right now right it is but um
it is energy intensive but if you're
using renewable
energy then it's like it's not a problem
that it's energy-intensive so that's
where you go back to electrify
everything uh it requires a fraction of
the land
and a fraction of the water and
doesn't contribute to air pollution and
sort of all of these
benefits um it is electricity intensive
but nevertheless you're still talking
about huge
gains even there because of all of the
extra stages of production that are
involved in conventional agriculture
uh but to to realize the big gains you
do need to be using
renewable energy in the factories
another criticism that that
gets hurled in in the direction of this
field is
the monocropping thing right because
we're talking about
basically pea and soy um what else
are the core ingredients in these
products for the plant-based
see but that that is a that is a pretty
fundamental misunderstanding
um of plant-based meat so it's p and soy
now
because p in soy is what's available um
and we're at very small scale but there
are people who would like to be
growing oats in north dakota and
wisconsin and other places
and oats can help to revitalize
the soil they can help to decrease
runoff there are all kinds of crops
and it's kind of protein as protein as
protein which is what we saw
with impossible version 1.0 moving to
impossible version
2.0 and they just changed their protein
because they needed uh they're using soy
because that's what they could get
in big supply but one of the great
things about this transition is
it requires so much less land which
means you don't have to mono crop again
90 of soy
is fed to chickens and other farm
animals right now
you can stop monocropping you can
produce crops that do a better job of
sequestering
carbon um you can rotate your crops um
you can produce different proteins
uh it will need to scale up so that the
supply chain is there and we're not
in that place yeah out there except with
peas and soy
but this is a solution to that problem
in a really big way because the vast
mono cropping happens right now uh
because corn
and soy and wheat are the primary crops
in animal feed
you remove the animal and you make a
much more efficient process which
decreases
stress on the land and allows for much
greater diversity
yeah and as we continue to iterate
and find more diverse
plant products to use for these um
alternatives uh you create a more
biodiverse
situation where you can rotate those
crops yeah no that's
that's exactly right that is exactly
right and i mean you know speaking again
i mean thinking again on a
global scale going from needing 4
billion
hectares of land to 1 billion hectare
of land that's good for the issue of
monocropping
in the united states which is where most
food activists are thinking about it
but it's really good for people for
subsistence farmers
in rain forests that are no longer going
to be burned down
to grow soy for farm animals it's really
good
in the entire developing world where
land is being taken over
in order to grow crops to feed the
animals or to graze animals because more
and more people
are eating meat from a biodiversity
standpoint
both ocean biodiversity
and land biodiversity um decreasing the
inefficiency
of production is just such a boon to the
natural world
i'd like to see this move towards uh
organic production as well i mean i
talked to pat about this
and he was like look i would have loved
to i'd love to have
organic soy for the impossible burger
there isn't enough
it's not being produced at the scale
that he required
but if we could create that
incentivization
or as new companies come online who want
to have
a premium product and are sourcing their
ingredients from
organic farms i think we're going to see
that i think we will
absolutely see that i think if you go
back to
anything that increases the price um
decreases the penetration um so at least
from gfi
standpoint like um people will say well
you should be encouraging these
companies to do organic or you should be
encouraging these companies to do a
wide range of things that would be good
for these companies to do or you should
when you're meeting with jbs or tyson or
cargill you should talk with them about
treatment of slaughterhouse workers or
whatever
the analogy that our general counsel
used in a slightly
uh different context is the
five-year-olds playing soccer
and the professional soccer team and one
of the things that i think
holds back progressives sometimes
is everybody feels like they have to do
everything and everything has to be
thoroughly integrated and it's like
we're all
charging the soccer ball and we don't
move the soccer ball forward
um so for gfi
we're playing professional soccer uh and
our focus is let's make sure these
products taste the same or better
and cost the same or less um and if you
are somebody
who is in a community that is going to
be hyper screwed
by climate change um you want
plant-based meat and cultivated meat
to taste the same or better and cost the
same or less as soon as possible
so that it can reap its maximum
advantage
and one of the things like one of our
team members said you know when you're
talking with jbs can we also
talk about slaughterhouse workers um and
the question is do you think
that we'll actually do some good yeah um
no there are lots of people talking to
them
about slaughterhouse workers do you
think that will sever our relationship
with
them and make it really hard for our
scientists to meet with their scientists
well yeah it will
sever our relationship with them so
there are lots of organizations
working on a full range of super worthy
awesome work across the full spectrum of
food justice
but in the same way that we're not going
to go to people who are working on
slaughterhouse minimum wage or worker
justice or whatever and say hey
can you integrate plant-based and
cultivated meat into your thinking about
this issue
because look at all the great things it
does for climate and antibiotic
resistance and pandemic risk and you
should be thinking more about that
we don't want them to do that they've
got their lane and they're focused on
something super worthy
and important i mean we've got our lane
and we're focused on something
um super worthy and important
on the policy front where are the
you know battlegrounds being drawn right
now like what are the what are the wars
that you're fighting i mean we're kind
of aware of the labeling laws and all
the kind of shenanigans that's going on
around what you can and can't call
products but you know from your
perspective
you know being immersed in this and
being in washington um
you know what's the what's what's the
biggest fight that we're facing right
now or that you're trying to
win we haven't hit newton's third law
in a really big way yet so there hasn't
been much in the way of equal and
opposite reaction
so when we're talking about like what
are the obstacles it's mostly inertia
it's mostly that people are doing a
gazillion things and nobody is looking
for one more thing to be put on their
plates
um so the stuff i am most excited about
um all has to do with convincing
the global climate community to take
food and agriculture seriously and to
put alternative proteins into how they
think about that
so working with the world economic forum
on
the un food systems summit with a view
of getting
alternative proteins into how the global
community on climate is thinking about
um solving climate problems using ag
using alternative proteins
um and then moving from the u.n food
system summit to cop26 and really making
sure
folks are talking about ag and are
talking about solutions that scale
globally
and then hey this is the one solution
that scales globally
but it's really it's inertia like you go
to environmental groups
they've set their strategic plans they
know what they're doing for the next
five years
they don't have all of this side budget
waiting for some new
initiative similarly on capitol hill
we have been super gratified by how many
members of congress like once you go and
you meet with them and you say hey
nobody's talking with you about a
solution that scales in agriculture
here's a solution that scales in
agriculture we organized
61 including the g including gfi we
organized 61
organizations to write to the relevant
house and senate committees for the
national science foundation
um and usda asking for 50 million
dollars each
for open access plant-based and
cultivated meat research and we got the
mushroom institute and the pea and
lentil council we got unilever we got
merc
we got greenpeace we got a consumers
union and a bunch of different groups
um and they all signed on which is a
great sign but
none of them were like oh i really need
one new you know project to spend
spend a bunch of time on um so it's
really
that nobody was looking for something
else to do and we need partners
um so so excited to be working with the
world
economic forum i'm so excited to be
meeting
uh with so many members of congress who
are enthusiastic about this
rosa deloro is probably the most
important person in the house of
representatives
for what we're trying to do and she has
been talking about
incentivizing plant-based and cultivated
meat
r d so making significant inroads uh
in congress is very exciting beginning
to meet make
inroads uh with environmental nonprofits
is exciting
um the university program with 16
campuses around
the world top universities for
agriculture and food service is exciting
the work with the big corporations as
well as startups and investors
is exciting and really
there isn't a lot of difficult
pushback but there is everybody is
insanely busy
all the time with really good stuff and
adding one more thing to agendas
is just hard i love the idea of creating
university curriculums in these
agricultural schools specifically
are there some great professors who are
like teaching this stuff i mean it seems
like
look this is going to be a trillion
dollar business right like this is the
future
how are we training or getting young
people thinking about this and
up to speed for this you know emerging
market
yeah it's very exciting and we've got an
entire program um
at berkeley we've got an entire program
at uc davis which is the
number two ag university in the world
we've been working with wagoningham
university in the netherlands which is
the number one ag university in the
world
working with them on proposals to the
government to fund even more of it
um worked with davis and
got them applying to national science
foundation and they got 3.5
million dollars to do uh cultivated meat
research and now they have a cultivated
meat modeling consortium
wow um our alternative protein project
uh the 16 university chapters is just on
fire these
students it is students who like they
want to save the world
they're excited about stem and for
example they got
two stanford professors to apply gfi has
a grant program so we have
three funders that give us a total of
five million dollars every year
to basically do a call for proposals and
fund
uh white space white space research um
and that is a great opportunity
for our affiliate organizations to go to
scientists like imbrapa
which is basically the the
ag research service of brazil
is coming to seminars with gfi
scientists uh the national institute of
food and agriculture at usda is coming
to seminars
with gfi scientists to like learn about
these issues
and then pairing scientists with money
and also having a pool of money
ourselves
really sort of shifts the way that
people look at gfi and shifts the way
that people think
about science in this space and it gives
our protein projects on these 16
university campuses
something to go speak with the relevant
professors about there's this money and
you're doing this tissue engineering
work or you're doing this plant biology
work
what do you think about putting a
proposal together for this pool of money
is is pretty pretty exciting and awesome
wow what efforts are underway
to facilitate the transition of these
ranchers and other farmers into
you know new way of doing things and
that's a big part of this right
that doesn't create that opportunity
there are a bunch of organizations
focused on
that specifically um we have
co-sponsored some legislation in
california that
incentivizes transition to
plant-based production gfi's
main focus honestly is getting
is funding the research and to the
transition on that
side of things but we are certainly and
we expect
just transitions at the policy level to
come alongside this
but right now we are early enough uh and
there is little enough government money
uh that then figuring out what you do in
terms of just transition
on the other side is probably a step or
two below
beyond uh but it's certainly something
that we're super enthusiastic about and
we've got the the pilot legislation in
california that we're enthusiastic about
i look at gfi and i see it as sort of
this
organization that is helping all of
these
budding entrepreneurs and scientists and
people who are interested in this field
turn red lights into green lights like
how can we be
over here making sure that your path can
unfold
more smoothly than it would otherwise um
is that fair yeah we see ourselves we
call it field cattle and we call
ourselves a field catalyst
which is sort of a think tank so you
know back to gfi.org is the wikipedia
of alternative proteins like we have a
startup guide that won an award from
fast company and we have investor
resources and we have an overwhelming
amount of
open access science and lots of stuff
for corporations to get up to speed and
investors to get up to speed so yeah
um it's about you know massive
facilitation for anybody
who could be a key part of this
transition and what are the other
white spaces that you're seeing right
now where you think
here's where this is going or here's
something that we're not paying
attention to that we should be paying
more attention to
um so we have something called advancing
solutions
in alternative proteins which is at
gfi.org
asap which is focused on specifically
answering that question um the two big
ones are scale
up so what does it look like to even
have the infrastructure
if plant-based meat continues to grow at
every single year um on the um
and then government funding uh to
basically
if you if you take out a loan to buy a
450 million dollar factory
on conventional terms the
capex costs are sort of through the roof
um elon musk credits tesla not going
bankrupt in 2009
uh with a government incentive program
that allowed him to take out a really
low
cost loan so incentivizing that sort of
thing
at the government level is a pretty big
one on cultivated meat
our techno-economic analysis identified
albumin
and figuring out how to markedly
decrease the cost of albumin as being
something that would be pretty
critically important
and back to working with universities so
the vaginium university research which
is the top ag university in the world
they looked at our asap uh advancing
solutions and
alternative proteins which is exactly
the question you just asked and there's
pages and pages of white space
opportunities on the website uh they
looked at that
and in a funding proposal to the dutch
government
um picked four of the white spaces that
we have identified
as white spaces that they would like to
fill which at gfi just
elates us beyond beyond because our goal
is to get
as much activity happening in this space
as possible
and as a field catalyst we think in
terms of 100x
you know not just 10x but 100x so if the
dutch government can solve four of these
peop
these problems um through wageningham
university research
um on the basis of the work that we did
on on asap uh which was about
a year's worth of work for a small team
of people at gfi
like that is just a massive massive
benefit and similarly if we can't
incentivize governments uh to put
billions of dollars
into open access r d or to incentivize
uh private sector activity in this space
it's you know
way beyond just gfi's resources it
opens up a massive and entire field and
that's how we think about our corporate
work our
uh innovation investor work our science
work
and our policy work so casting your gaze
forward
i don't know 20 years 50 years
what does the world look like if you're
able to accomplish all of these goals
that you've set
for yourself and for gfi um
what does the world look like yeah um
i imagine all the all the lights are
green all the way
and all these things that you're working
on all these companies that you're
babysitting and
um helping facilitate and all and the
next generation of
scientists that you're you know trying
to
birth into the world are able to go off
and do the thing
yeah i mean even just on the plant-based
and cultivated meat side when somebody
says how quickly
could we replace commodity meat so
lowest common denominator
meat how quickly could we replace that
with plant-based and cultivated meat
further to what you said a little bit
ago if like somebody in china gets the
fire lit under them and they say you
know we are as a country
going to have bragging rights until the
end of time
for being the country that made meat
from plants and cultivated meat from
cells and eliminated
the pandemic risk and antibiotic use
and various other global health and
environmental
scorches slashed the climate impact of
me like china could make
all of this happen pretty quickly they
have world-class universities i mean if
you read about
why solar panels are the cost that they
are now
or why lithium-ion ion batteries are the
cost and are as efficient as they are
now like that's china
and we shouldn't let that happen with me
so we should be able to incentivize
something similar
in the united states and right now the
u.s is the uncontested
global leader in alternative proteins
but israel and singapore are you know
coming along and their governments are
the uncontested governments that are
taking it most seriously but we've got
beyond an impossible and just in memphis
and blue net loo
that aspect of what we're talking about
replacing
lowest common denominator meat with meat
made from plants and meat cultivated
from cells
is really a question of will
incentivization and funding and could
happen pretty quickly
um and then our hope is that alongside
that you know back further to the
professional
soccer team um our hope is that
you would see i mean right by definition
the jobs are better
by definition there is less stress on
land
um by definition most of the things that
would meet
make for a truly just food system and
you know we we could
replace commodity meat with plant-based
and
cultivated meat and change kind of
none of the structures that exist right
now and that would still be we'll treat
the workers terribly
still do all these other things that we
need to change and that's still
i mean that's still if you're you know
somebody if you're one of the 700
million people who are
living in abject poverty globally or one
of the 200 million that are
you know just sent there uh by coven 19
like that's
better that's a lot better than the
current system
uh but my ideal is that we you know the
professional soccer team we make
progress across all of these issues um
and
as there is less stress on the land we
do move toward
um organic we do completely abandon
monocropping and other things that
destroy the soil we do
take um what we learned in and kiss the
earth
seriously about soil regeneration
um and you know beating back the toxins
and everything else and
we take worker concerns seriously and we
incorporate environmental justice into
our thinking across all of these issues
both
factories and where the factories are
placed and how farmland
is distributed and who gets incentivized
and i think all of that gets easier if
we're you know if we're not
incentivized to monocrop and if we're
making meat from plants and cultivating
meat from cells
um i also think that we can completely
rethink
our relationship with animals if
the vast majority of people are not in a
relationship that you know is supporting
industrial animal agriculture i think we
can think um in whole
new and more open ways about who animals
are and
how they are et cetera um so i think
this can be a part of
creating just a much better world across
the full
range of issues uh where the world is
broken
right now beautifully put i think that's
a good place to
wrap it up can i say one last thing of
course
um gfi is hiring yeah and the last get
to that i wasn't gonna let i was gonna
end this i was gonna
okay culminate it with a big monologue
about gfi
oh that's very nice i know that you're
uh i mean
you've been hiring like crazy since
since i met you and this has gone on
unabated so if people want to get
involved in addition to just going to
gfi.org and
spending time on the website and reading
all of the literature that you have
available there
there are also multiple opportunities
and avenues to get involved but perhaps
you could even get
hired by bruce to work there that's
exactly right we have a whole bunch of
openings and people can find them at
gfi.org
careers and like you said we are we are
often
and somewhat uh constantly hiring so we
keep growing and we do have openings uh
not just in the united states but also
india
israel brazil asia pacific out of
singapore
uh and all over europe but uh our policy
offices in brussels
yeah and anything else that i didn't
address or
left out um i mean my hiring pitch is
that gfi takes mindfulness
very very seriously we have incorporated
daniel pink's theory of vocational
self-actualization and how we think
about
working at gfi so everybody gets
a headspace account if you work at gfi
we start our leadership team meetings as
well as our staff meetings with two
minutes
of breathing in all things good and
breathing out all things bad
and we really take seriously the idea
that what people
want from their vocations um is a high
degree
of figuring out how to do your work not
being told how to do it so
we were calling it autonomy and we had
some sort of uh misperceptions of what
autonomy means you're still hired to do
your specific job to do whatever i want
yes that was the
that was that was the pitfall a little
bit but um we i don't think there is a
better place
to vocationally self-actualize than gfi
and especially for people who are
scientists or policy advocates
and if you're at an environmental
organization don't come to gfi get your
environmental organization to go all
in on this but this is how we stop the
next pandemic that's how we keep
antibiotics working it's how we
address climate change um and we really
do need
all hands on deck on this so check out
our website get involved come to our
webinars come to our conferences
and yeah i think that's basically it and
and
be a meaningful participant in
change positive change and then to that
thing man
thank you my friend i love you if
there's anything i can do to support
your work
we live in crazy amazing fantastical
times it's going to be very interesting
to
observe how all of this plays out over
the next couple years and you're
certainly welcome back here any time
to share what you find out in the world
thank you so much rich i love you too
um and just absolutely who you are in
the world and how you exist in the world
and how you use your
uh podcast to raise consciousness about
everything good
uh is just truly inspiring so uh it's an
honor
to be on the podcast and then honor to
be uh friends uh and compatriots and
making the
world better and more just so thank you
very much and now i'm gonna have to
start
our day here with uh two minutes of
breathing in good and breathing out bad
it is so good it is so good breathing in
we are breathing in peace equanimity and
all things good
breathing out we are breathing out
strife consternation and all things bad
starting now amen brother amen
peace plats peace plants
you